now the most important story of the day
I don't want to forget about immigration
forget about the economy collapsing
forget about the bank runs forget about
World War III
I want to congratulate Miller Lite
Miller Lite
is following its own truth
it's going against
the conservative cancel mob okay it's
standing up Miller Lite
is at least as gay
as Bud Light take it away
here's a little known fact women were
among the very first to brew beer ever
from Mesopotamia to the Middle Ages to
colonial America women were the ones
doing the Brewing centuries later how
did the industry pay homage to the
founding mothers of beer they put us in
bikinis
wow
look at this wild it's time beer made it
up to women so today Miller Lite is on a
mission to clean up not just their the
whole beer Industries
Miller Lite has been scouring the
internet for all this and buying it back
so that he can turn it into good shop
for women Brewers literally good how you
ask ladies take it away first we turn
the badge into compost now we feed
compost to worms pushed out beautiful
fertilizer
that good helps Farmers grow quality
hops
which has been donated to women Brewers
to make their own really good but
there's definitely more out there
in your attic in the garage and your
parents basement send any you got
into Miller Lite and they'll turn that
into good too
oh
so here's to women because without us
there would be no
[Music]
this is the Cleopatra of Bud Light
commercials this is
Miller Lite is now the Netflix of
Brewers
actually did you know beer was invented
by women
I mean it wasn't but we're but let's
just say so did you know actually
Cleopatra was black I can't wait for the
next documentary from Netflix on George
Washington starring Spike Lee it's going
to be really great
this is it so okay there's this
historical claim
is that beer was invented by women or
has been produced by women for centuries
or whatever which is obviously not true
if you're going to give credit to any
group I guess you should give it to
monks right wasn't it the monks who
really began brewing and popularizing
beer okay fine
then you get to the next level which is
in the past
we've sold beer by putting pictures of
pretty women in bikinis on our
advertisements and that was terrible so
now we're going to put very angry
feminists
very very sort of frumpy clothing that's
how we're gonna sell beer to our
customer base that's totally going to
convince them
and then the third part which irritates
me frankly even more than the first two
which is
women saying
that we
we love to say naughty language you know
if I say s-h-i-t that's that's gonna
make me cool and hip it's like all these
female comedians who just think if they
talk about their genitals and say some
four-letter words that's a a
substitute for a joke and for comedy
it's not
it's not at all Miller Lite huh you know
what I say Miller Light in the loafers
is what they are these days
I'll see myself at now good night
everybody now it's it's
differently woke than the Bud Light
commercial and I should point out the
the Miller Lite commercial came out
before the Bud Light commercial and no
one noticed it and people are only
noticing it now after the big backlash
so I'm sure Miller executives are doing
their best to try to downplay this
commercial I bet it was Bud Light
opposition researchers who found this
for Miller and they're popularizing this
right now
but
it it's differently woke the Bud Light
commercial the Bud Light can with Dylan
Mulvaney was woke in that it was
adopting this radical new anthropology
so it was positioning itself as fun and
happy and Light
with Miller you're seeing the flip side
of wokeness or the flip side of
liberalism that's all it really is she's
the basic old word which is they're
really negative angry side the side of
resentment the side with a chip on the
shoulder it's the same practical effect
which is insulting the people who
actually buy these beers
but you're seeing both sides
there's the happy glitzy facade and then
the underlying angry reality of it as
I've said before though I'm not worried
about Miller Lite now no I can't drink
Miller Lite or oh no I can't drink Bud
Light
because I prefer to drink white claw
when I'm drinking a canned alcohol and
white Claw is already so gay that it
will never have to prove its liberal
Bona fides by pandering to the wokies or
by insulting it's customer base which is
great I love that I get to drink my
mango
hard Seltzer in peace right now go to
cinch.com use promo code Knolls the
weather is warming up in Nashville which
means that everyone's gearing up for
backyard barbecues and campfires the
last thing you need to be doing while
getting ready to host a barbecue is
driving around worrying about where to
refill your propane grill tank that is
why you need to check out cinch cinch is
a propane grill tank Home Delivery
Service they deliver propane grill tanks
right to your door cinch delivers on
your schedule requires no long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to wait around at home track the order
on the Cinch app from anywhere whether
you're grilling steaks or lighting up
the patio heaters on a cold night
cinches propane delivery service ensures
that you have the fuel you need to make
the most of every moment go online right
now to cinch.com or order the Cinch app
okay you download that app you can make
your orders new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just ten dollars
with promo code
that is cinch.com or you get that cinch
app use promo code Knolls kwles to get
your first tank exchange for just ten
dollars this is a limited time offer you
must live within a cinched service area
to redeem it go to cinch.com
cynch.com offer for details president
Trump
I think he made a little bit of a
misstep and so in a spirit of friendship
and love and care I would encourage him
to maybe not go down the path that he
appears to be going down which is
president Trump is positioning himself
to the left of Ron DeSantis on the issue
of life and I think this is a huge
mistake
Trump
was discussing the abortion ban now the
six-week abortion ban in Florida that
that Ron DeSantis is behind and Trump
said quote
he has to do what he has to do if you
look at what DeSantis did a lot of
people don't even know if he knew what
he was doing but he signed six weeks and
many people within the pro-life
Community feel that was too harsh
so just
to correct the record as a card-carrying
member in good standing of the pro-life
community
nobody within the pro-life Community
thinks six weeks is too harsh we think
that six weeks is too lenient because a
person is a person no matter how small
and it's always wrong to murder people
and so if anything at all a six-week ban
is too lenient might be a good
incremental step in the right direction
but murder is either wrong or it isn't
and abortion either ends a human life or
it doesn't
and there's no way to meet in the middle
we've talked about this a lot with
transgenderism frankly it's even clearer
on the issue of abortion there were some
issues where we can find a conciliatory
middle ground and everybody can Kumbaya
and be happy on tax rates on immigration
policy on foreign policy on trade and
all sorts of things
but on a question like life
it's kind of a binary question can we
kill babies or not
should we murder innocent little babies
or not
if the baby is a baby if abortion ends a
human life then you shouldn't be allowed
to do it
if abortion does not end to human life
if the baby's not really a baby if it's
some other kind of thing it's a mere
clump of cells or it's not a human or
not alive or whatever then there's no
reason that you should really limit
abortion at all this is why Hillary
Clinton's answer on abortion the safe
legal and rare answer on abortion is so
silly
if abortion is murder then it shouldn't
be legal if abortion is not murder then
it should not be rare there's no reason
for it to be rare I think this is a huge
mistake for Trump too just politically
because Trump is the guy who overruled
Roe v Wade as he pointed out elsewhere
in that statement but that's what he's
gonna that's what he should run on he's
the greatest hero to the pro-life
movement that we've ever seen okay run
on it win it Americans are pro-life the
Republican base is very pro-life
why would you ever see that territory to
your primary rival your Chief primary
rival when you've got the best record on
it
it's a huge mistake to run to the left
of DeSantis that the knock on desantis's
campaign right now is that he has
support from people within the
establishment
it's not even necessarily desantis's
fault he's just he's not Trump he's the
biggest threat to Trump and so people in
The Establishment are more inclined to
support him so if you're Trump
you know that your base your guys are
the hardcore ones they're the
bloodthirsty ones they're the
paradoxically though on the issue of
Life they're actually the ones who who
don't want to to shed blood they're the
ones who are the great Defenders of life
so just go for it man you're Donald
Trump be Donald Trump don't don't meet
people in the middle okay especially on
something like life especially on
something that is that is the most
important aspect of your legacy
When Donald Trump is remembered he might
be remembered for a handful of things
but the chief accomplishment that man
has to his name the most important thing
that man has ever done in his life
is to appoint the judges
who overruled Roe v Wade who will over
the course of the years
hundreds of thousands millions of babies
will be saved because of what Donald
Trump did so run on it man don't see
that ground to DeSantis I know what
you're thinking that was a great clip if
you want more if you want the longer
form interviews if you want the yes or
no game if you want face off if you want
the breakouts if you want the full show
you got it subscribe ring that Bell
Michael Knowles YouTube channel see you
next time